Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous
et très heureuse de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle saison
de "Politiques à table" sur LCP,
toujours autour d'un invité,
d'un plat et d'un dessert.
Nous sommes ensemble
pendant une heure.
Pour bien démarrer
cette année gastronomique,
nous recevons
un invité exceptionnel :
Yves Camdeborde.
Bonjour.
-Bonjour, bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Avec moi
en plateau,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
Bonjour.
-Bonjour, Brigitte.
Yves Camdeborde,
vous êtes chef cuisinier, pionnier
de la bistronomie,
mi-bistrot, mi-gastro.
Vous avez inspiré
de jeunes chefs avec la Régalade
et avec le Comptoir du Relais
à Saint-Germain.
Vous avez inventé
une cuisine de terroir,
avec des produits frais,
de qualité,
accessibles à tous,
vous qui avez pourtant été
élevé dans les cuisines
du Ritz,
de la Tour d'Argent et du Crillon,
où vous avez suivi
votre mentor Christian Constant.
Vous avez changé
la restauration parisienne
en vous focalisant
sur le produit, le goût.
Vous étiez à l'avant-garde
du local, devenu l'objectif
des consommateurs.
Le local,
on va le retrouver
dans le menu du jour.
-Oui, avec un menu qui sent le sud :
brandade de morue.
En dessert, une crème caramel.
-Dans Le dessous des plats,
connaissez-vous la bistronomie
d'un étoilé,
dans un décor décontracté ?
Dégustation au Matré,
un restaurant parisien
du 18e arrondissement.
-Ensuite, comment mangent
les rugbymen ?
De la collation d'avant-match
au banquet final, reportage.
-On passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Avec un convive comme vous, Yves,
chef et rugbyman,
on est surpris,
dans notre assiette.
Ca dépend de l'heure du match :
si on mange avant, mauvaise pioche,
c'est pâtes et poulet,
pas très glamour,
laissons ça au XV de France,
et si c'est après match,
à en croire votre livre,
"Ovalix : une histoire
"gourmande du rugby",
que je montre,
la 3e mi-temps,
c'est la régalade, sans clin d'oeil,
entre banquet
et gueuleton.
On s'est mis à rêver :
pourquoi pas ripailler ce soir
avec un faisan de Bohème
sur croustade,
une truite saumonée à la russe ?
Je n'invente rien,
ce sont des plats tirés
d'un menu de 1896
pour un match international
de l'Olympique.
Non, rien de tout ça.
Pour sortir de cette mêlée,
vous nous avez pris à contrepied
avec une brandade de morue,
qui me laisse pantois.
Quel désaveu
pour votre terroir de Pau
et votre club de coeur,
la Section Paloise,
qui ne comprendra pas
cette oeillade
en direction du RC Nîmes.
Ca mérite
des explications.
-Parce que c'est un plat
de saison.
C'est un plat à mi-chemin
entre la fin de l'été
et le début de l'automne,
et c'est surtout un plat
qui a du caractère.
Je suis du sud-ouest,
mais j'aime la cuisine de caractère.
Peu importe d'où elle vient,
l'important, c'est de pas y mettre
de l'indifférence.
La brandade de morue,
c'est un joli plat
un joli clin d'oeil
au terroir du sud-ouest.
-C'est un plat
que vous proposez ?
-Oui.
Je la mets toujours à la carte.
Pour la petite histoire,
je l'ai apprise avec papa.
Il avait travaillé
dans les années 50 à Paris.
C'est là-bas qu'il avait appris
à faire la brandade de morue.
Elle est particulière,
elle est un peu parmentière.
On y incorpore...
-Voilà, racontez-nous.
-Il y a plusieurs façons
de faire la brandade de morue.
La tradition des grands
classiques français...
Il y a autant de recettes
que nous avons de grands-mères.
Chaque famille a
son secret,
sa façon de faire.
La brandade parmentière,
c'est une morue qui a été pochée,
souvent dans du lait
parfumé avec de l'ail,
du thym et du laurier,
qu'on égoutte,
qu'on monte à l'huile d'olive
avec un ail haché.
Après, on y ajoute, voilà,
une purée
de pommes de terre
pour l'onctuosité.
-On va appeler Jean-Pierre
à la rescousse.
Y a-t-il de la pomme de terre
dans la brandade ?
-Trois choses à savoir.
Je fais preuve d'humilité
devant un chef.
Trois choses à éclaircir.
Vous avez tout dit.
Y a-t-il des pommes de terre
dans l'authentique brandade ?
-Non.
-Donc c'est pas l'authentique,
la vôtre ?
-C'est une brandade parmentière.
-Vaut-il mieux
faire cuire la morue dans du lait ?
Si oui, pourquoi ?
-On le fait cuire
dans du lait parce que, déjà,
le lait va dessaler
plus pertinemment que l'eau,
et surtout,
le lait va blanchir la morue qui,
étant donné qu'elle a été
séchée et lavée
et qu'il y a
des couleurs foncées...
Ca permet d'avoir une brandade
avec une couleur or.
-L'ail est-il indispensable
pour faire prendre la brandade ?
Ca vient de "brander", "tourner".
-Oui.
C'est écraser.
L'ail est-il indispensable ?
Pour mon épouse, non :
elle en veut pas,
mais moi, j'en veux.
-C'est une question
de modération, non ?
Faut pas en mettre trop,
de l'ail.
-C'est une question de goût.
Pour moi, c'est indispensable
parce que c'est un exhausteur
de goût.
Ca va amener de la profondeur
et ça va permettre
de garder un palais
relativement puissant
mais tellement agréable.
-Ca favorise l'émulsion, non,
avec l'huile ?
-Voilà, ça permet un liant,
à l'huile d'olive.
Dans la façon classique,
on met pas de pommes de terre.
C'est l'ail qui va apporter
ce côté crémeux.
En mixant l'ail et l'huile,
on aura une crème
qui va s'enrouler
autour de la morue pochée.
Mais je le redis,
il y a autant
de recettes
que de grands-mères.
-Vous aviez 2 lieux,
la Régalade, le Comptoir du Relais,
que vous n'avez plus aujourd'hui.
Un chef, aujourd'hui,
sans ses cuisines,
cuisine à la maison ?
Comment ça se fait ?
-Quand j'avais mes cuisines,
je cuisinais à la maison.
Cuisiner, pour moi, c'est vital.
-Vous êtes aux fourneaux
à la maison ?
C'est pas votre femme ?
-Mon épouse cuisine bien, mais non,
j'y prends un réel plaisir,
et je suis dans mon élément.
-Plus de plaisir
sans client derrière,
parce que vous avez le temps ?
C'est plus détendu ?
-Beaucoup plus.
Je pense qu'inconsciemment,
je détends beaucoup plus
la matière première aussi,
parce que je lui amène pas
mon stress,
inhérent
à mon métier de restaurateur.
Je le fais
dans une forme de jovialité,
de décontraction,
et puis je pense
que je cuisine mieux à la maison,
car j'ai moins de réflexions
par rapport au visuel.
Je ne vais qu'au goût.
Exemple avec un petit pois.
Au restaurant,
il sera toujours vert fluo,
car il aura été cuit
dans de l'eau salée,
glacé, tandis qu'à la maison,
je le cuis
dans le jus du poulet,
il prend la couleur marbrée,
pas très jolie,
mais c'est meilleur !
-C'est vous, le client,
avec moins d'exigences.
-Beaucoup moins.
-C'est pas mauvais.
Ca ressemble...
-C'est la recette
de chez Françoise,
le restaurant des Invalides,
avec qui nous travaillons.
-On dirait que ça ressemble
au parmentier d'Yves.
-On est entre deux.
On est vraiment entre les deux.
On ressent la puissance de la morue,
qui est très présente
et très agréable.
La façon dont j'ai appris avec papa,
on est plus sur un petit gratin
de pommes de terre à la morue,
avec plus d'onctuosité,
mais moins de puissance
de morue.
Je pense que l'amateur de brandade,
le puriste, il va adorer.
-Il va l'aimer comme ça ?
Là, il y a du poisson.
Dans le sud-ouest, on est habitué
à des gésiers, à du canard, etc.
Vous,
vous consommez comment,
aujourd'hui ?
-Aujourd'hui,
j'ai changé mon alimentation
il y a une vingtaine d'années.
Le métier a pris conscience
des problématiques de surproduction
de protéines animales.
Donc, on a énormément réduit
notre consommation
de protéines animales.
Je dois en consommer
deux fois par semaine.
Le reste, c'est protéines végétales
et légumes.
On peut dire merci
à Alain Passard,
qui a anobli,
il y a bon nombre d'années,
mais qui a anobli la façon
de travailler le légume.
On y met de l'intention,
de la précision
sur la cuisson des légumes,
et on arrive à faire
des plats succulents
qui, gustativement,
apportent du plaisir.
-Toujours cette question épineuse...
Ca revient souvent ici,
c'est le foie gras.
On en fait quoi ?
On continue ?
-Bien sûr,
mais comme tous les produits
qui ont été pris
par l'industrie agroalimentaire,
qui a voulu produire
des quantités énormes,
énormes,
et qui a complètement déstabilisé
le produit par lui-même.
-Le petit éleveur gave aussi
son canard.
-Oui,
mais un petit éleveur
qui gave son canard,
il le fait à la main.
Pour approcher un canard,
il faut que le canard sente
de l'affection et de l'amour.
C'est vraiment fait
sans maltraitance de l'animal.
-Donc,
oui pour les petits éleveurs ?
-Revenons-y.
On peut parler aussi du saumon.
Le saumon fumé,
c'est une catastrophe,
une catastrophe totale.
-Les élevages
en Norvège...
-Catastrophique.
Il faut revenir
aux produits artisanaux,
en petites quantités,
et respecter la saison.
Le foie gras, on n'en mangeait
qu'à partir d'octobre,
novembre, décembre, janvier.
-Donc, le local,
la saisonnalité...
Le bio aussi ?
Vous le défendez ?
-Bien sûr.
Avec tous les entrants chimiques...
On sait très bien
que quels qu'ils soient,
ils sont dangereux
pour la santé de l'humain.
Il faut arriver à consommer
que des produits propres.
-Ca ne marche pas.
C'est une baisse record.
C'est très cher.
Les gens n'adhèrent pas.
On se perd dans les labels.
Le bio n'est pas privilégié.
-Le bio est en train de grandir,
en train de se remettre en question.
Là, il y a eu une évolution
assez incroyable du bio
parce que tout le monde
s'en est emparé.
Laissons le bio
à la petite échelle...
Ca a un coût un peu plus élevé,
mais je pense, je crois
que je préfère mettre
1 euro de plus dans une carotte
et moins acheter de médicaments,
voilà.
-On peut nourrir toute la population
avec des petites exploitations ?
Il faut pas aussi
des plus grandes...
-Non, on n'y arrivera
sans doute pas,
mais les petites exploitations
doivent exister,
et la vraie question,
et la vraie évolution passera
par une production conventionnelle
par l'agroalimentaire,
mais avec des règles sanitaires
très strictes
pour qu'ils puissent produire,
que tout le monde puisse manger
à sa faim, de façon propre.
On y arrivera.
-Un mot sur le vin.
Vous nous avez demandé
un vin nature.
Alors, un vin nature, c'est quoi ?
C'est un vin
qui n'a pas de pesticide,
dont les raisins sont bios.
Pas de pesticide,
pas d'engrais chimiques,
aucun entrant, vous l'avez dit.
Surtout, il n'y a pas
de sulfites ajoutés.
Donc, c'est entièrement naturel.
Le risque,
c'est que ça peut repartir un peu
en fermentation.
-Non. Non, non, non.
Non, il n'y a pas de risque
quand c'est bien fait. Aucun risque.
Il faut que ce soit fait
par des vignerons,
et ça se fera pas en un jour,
par rapport au travail de la terre.
Il faut qu'elle soit habituée,
et que le raisin soit habitué
à vivre sans entrants chimiques,
par rapport aux ceps de vigne.
Quand c'est fait
dans les règles de l'art,
de façon traditionnelle,
il n'y a aucun risque.
Le problème du vin nature,
c'est qu'on parle de nature
alors qu'il y a des déviants
dans le vin.
Non, c'est pas bon !
-C'est qu'il est mal fait ?
-Il est mal fait.
-Le soufre permet justement
d'éviter cette altération.
-Voilà, après,
il y a aussi des vins nature
avec un minimum de soufre
pour stabiliser le vin.
Il faut pas être contre ça non plus.
Il faut pas être braqué
par rapport aux entrants,
mais dans l'absolu,
si on peut le faire
sans entrants chimiques,
c'est mieux pour la santé.
C'est mieux pour la santé...
Voilà,
c'est mieux pour nous !
Allons vers ça.
-Brigitte,
j'ai une question.
Un vin nature,
c'est plus radical qu'un vin bio ?
-C'est un peu plus radical...
Oui, parce qu'il n'y a pas
de soufre, en fait.
-C'est ce qui fait la différence ?
-C'est le cahier des charges...
-Sans sulfites ajoutés.
-Au-delà du bio. OK.
-Une appellation stricte.
-Si c'est pas bon,
peu importe que ce soit bio,
nature ou conventionnel,
quand c'est pas bon,
c'est pas bon.
-Alors, là,
on est sur un vin de Loire,
c'est un chinon.
J'espère que ça se marie bien
avec la brandade de morue.
-Justement,
quand on parle de brandade,
on pourrait penser de suite
à un vin blanc,
tandis que là,
c'est un cabernet franc, je pense...
-Oui, effectivement.
-Il se marie...
Il tient bien.
-Millésime 2021.
-Il tient bien avec la morue,
qui a du caractère, qui est salée,
et avec même le côté un peu aillé.
Il est vraiment en place.
C'est un mariage tout en fraîcheur.
-On est sur les fruits rouges.
-Ouais, complètement,
sur les fruits rouges.
On croque vraiment
dans le côté très fruité
de la cerise,
de la framboise,
de la fraise.
C'est très agréable.
-Alors, vous êtes très fort,
car vous êtes chef,
mais on va voir
si vous êtes incollable.
C'est le quiz.
-Brigitte l'a rappelé,
vous avez fait
vos classes
à la Tour d'Argent,
qui vient justement de rouvrir
après des mois
de travaux titanesques.
C'était incroyable.
Sauriez-vous me dire,
sur cette fameuse Tour d'Argent,
une institution,
si ces affirmations sont
vraies ou fausses ?
-La A, c'est faux.
-Bravo. Pourquoi ?
-Je crois que le plus vieux
restaurant de France,
c'est Le Procope,
ou sur l'île Saint-Louis,
un petit établissement
dont le nom m'échappe...
-Alors, moi, j'ai lu que c'était
le plus vieux restaurant de France,
mais c'est pas en 1810,
mais en 1852,
plus vieux que Le Procope.
-Ah, j'ai un doute.
Je pense qu'il y a un établissement
dans l'île Saint-Louis...
-C'est présenté comme...
-On va faire un fact-checking.
Je vais vous fact-checker.
-Un fact-quiz.
Alors, la suite.
-Euh...
Il en était bien capable.
C'était un vrai gastronome,
Henri IV.
C'est mon roi, quand même.
Il est né au château de Pau.
Je pense que oui.
-Je ne sais pas,
mais ce que j'ai trouvé
dans les menus de l'époque,
c'était plutôt
du cygne rôti.
Le héron, je suis pas sûr
qu'on le farcissait,
mais peut-être.
La suite.
-Oh non,
la fourchette,
c'est Catherine de Médicis.
-En France.
-C'est elle qui l'a
amenée à la Renaissance.
On va dire...
Je sais pas, je fais mon joker.
-Vous avez raison, vous avez
bien commencé, Catherine de Médicis,
la Toscane,
la fourchette vient d'Italie
et c'est à la Tour d'Argent
que pour la 1re fois
on a mangé avec.
-C'est pratique finalement.
On l'a gardée.
-Avant, ils mangeaient
avec les doigts, non ?
-Oui, oui. Non, pas les doigts,
peut-être aussi avec des couverts,
des écuelles
ou des louches en bois.
Le bois.
-Et question pour aussi Brigitte,
les caves
du restaurant abritent
80 000 bouteilles.
-Euh, là, je dis oui,
parce que je les ai visitées
et c'est un labyrinthe.
D'ailleurs, il y a 4, 5 sous-sols
en dessous de la Seine
et raconté par M. Terrail,
pendant la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
pour pas que les Allemands
viennent voler les bouteilles,
ils avaient carrément
muré des couloirs
et sont pas sûrs
de les avoir tous démurés.
-Il y en a peut-être plus !
-Les 80 000 y sont.
-Vous aviez dû boire
un verre lors de ce tour,
car il y en avait
350 000. 350 000 bouteilles !
-Je savais
que c'était astronomique.
-350 000 bouteilles !
-80 000,
c'est déjà pas mal.
-Si vous avez l'occasion
de les visiter, c'est incroyable,
et ça descend, je crois, 4,
5 niveaux en dessous de la Seine.
-Et en cas de crue ?
-Ils ont
tout un système de pompes justement
pour éviter les inondations.
-Ce serait
une catastrophe.
-C'est fabuleux
à visiter.
-Ah oui, j'imagine.
-Vous allez pouvoir
vous rattraper.
De quel pays,
parmi les 20
engagés dans cette Coupe
du Monde de Rugby
le kokoda,
plat de poisson cru
au lait de coco,
est-il originaire ?
Le kokoda.
Alors, A, la Nouvelle-Zélande,
B, les Fidji,
C, l'Uruguay
et D, les îles Tonga.
-Alors, bon, l'Uruguay, je dis non.
La Nouvelle-Zélande, je dis non,
c'est soit les Tonga
soit les Fidji
et dans mon imaginaire, je suis
jamais allé sur les îles Fidji,
mais on voit souvent
des reportages sur les plages,
les joueurs fidjiens jouant
sous les cocotiers, donc les Fidji.
-Bravo ! Félicitations !
C'est exactement ça.
-Pour l'anecdote,
au Tonga, ils ont un peu
la même recette,
mais elle s'appelle pas kokoda.
C'est bien les îles
Fidji, bravo !
-C'est souvent
autour de la table et à l'occasion
d'un déjeuner, vous le savez,
que les langues se délient,
que finalement
les meilleures histoires
sont racontées.
C'est la brève de comptoir.
Yves Camdeborde, on vous a demandé
de réfléchir à une anecdote
autour d'un repas,
et si possible en politique. Y en
a-t-il une qui vous est revenue ?
-Oui, il y en a une.
Elle m'est pas revenue,
parce qu'elle est ancrée en moi,
c'est, je crois, en 1998,
quand il y avait eu la grève
des pilotes d'Air France,
c'était une grève qui avait duré
et qui avait été très, très engagée,
et j'avais
Christian Paris,
qui était un ami et qui était le
syndicaliste qui menait cette grève,
qui était pilote à Air France,
qui était très engagé
contre le ministre
à l'époque, qui était un
ministre qui était de Béziers,
qui s'appelait Monsieur Gayssot,
et c'est Michel Palmié,
qu'on appelait la momie,
l'emblématique seconde ligne
de l'équipe de France de rugby
de la grande époque
de l'équipe de Béziers,
qui avait 10 titres
de champion de France,
il connaissait les deux
et, à un moment donné, il me dit,
il savait qu'ils venaient
tous manger à la maison,
mais de façon individuelle...
-A la Régalade ?
-Oui. Et il me dit,
Yves, il faut qu'on dénoue ça,
prépare-moi une table, je vais
les amener, les assoir face à face
à table. Il me dit, tu vas voir,
la table, ça calme tout le monde,
ça met tout le monde au même niveau.
Fais un repas gargantuesque
et on va
discuter. Michel Palmié a fait
venir Monsieur le Ministre
et Christian Paris.
Ils se sont assis tous les trois.
-Ils étaient tous les 3 ?
-Tous les 3. La table 9,
une table qui était à part.
Ils se sont mis à table à midi,
ils en sont sortis...
-A quelle heure ?
-Il était presque 20h.
-Avec un accord alors ?
-Oui, avec un accord. Mais surtout,
durant le repas, une fois de plus,
le fait de manger,
le fait de partager permet aux gens
de s'écouter.
-Qu'est-ce que vous leur avez
préparé ? Il devait y avoir
quelque chose de bon.
-A l'époque, j'avais fait
une tarte de Saint-Jacques,
feuilletée avec du lard
et des oignons. On avait fait
un boeuf bourguignon,
un beau fromage
de brebis des Pyrénées
et le fameux gâteau russe.
Le gâteau russe,
c'était une spécialité
d'Oloron-Sainte-Marie,
que je recevais de mon ami
Michel Artigarrède.
Je leur avais fait ce repas.
Ca avait apaisé tout le monde.
A la fin de la journée,
ils s'étaient salués, embrassés
et ils avaient dit, c'est fini.
J'étais très fier d'avoir vécu
ce moment-là, parce que, pour moi,
la table a toujours été
un moyen de discuter,
de partager, de m'engager.
-On peut se disputer aussi
à table. Les repas de famille,
c'est parfois un peu...
-Oui,
mais on est à égalité.
Moi, j'aurais jamais pu
me disputer
avec une personne dans la rue
en la rencontrant,
mais une fois
que j'étais assis à table,
je n'avais plus aucun complexe,
je libérais ma parole,
j'avais une franchise naturelle.
Ce jour-là, la table a amené
la franchise
et a amené aussi le bon sens.
Le bon sens
de bien manger
et le bon sens de bien comprendre.
-Pensez-vous modestement
que ce que vous avez fourni
à ces convives, les plats
ont permis diplomatiquement
de nouer cet accord ?
Si vous aviez servir
quelque chose d'urticant,
de clivant, ça aurait pas joué
le même rôle ?
-Sans doute, c'est surtout
un état d'esprit. Ca avait été
fait avant moi.
Brillat-Savarin, c'était
Taillerand le ministre
qui l'avait engagé à son service
pour les grandes réunions politiques
justement pour adoucir
tous les autres présidents
des autres pays. Il savait
pertinemment que la gastronomie
française est respectée
et quand on mange de la gastronomie
française, on respecte le moment.
-On continue
à mettre en lumière
cette belle cuisine
française.
-Briseur de grève !
-Oui. Et je rends hommage
à Michel Palmié, à Christian
et à Monsieur Gayssot,
à tous les quatre,
chacun avec notre savoir, on était
arrivés à dénouer une situation
qui semblait indénouable.
-Inextricable,
bravo !
-A l'époque,
c'était déjà
un savoir-faire français,
la bistronomie.
Vous en êtes l'inventeur.
C'est le dessous des plats.
Une cuisine raffinée et inventive,
mais dans un cadre simple. Voilà
la définition de la bistronomie.
Née dans les années 90, elle a fait
florès dans la restauration,
des produits de qualité
à des prix exceptionnels,
les clients ne s'y trompent pas,
ils sont au rendez-vous
comme au Matré,
où Maïté Frémont et Raphaël Azenbar
ont rencontré un chef
que vous connaissez bien.
-Dans ce restaurant,
les tables sont simples, le style,
celui d'un bistrot typique.
Mais ici, le client
est bien loin d'une nourriture
parfois ordinaire.
-Le produit est hyper important,
donner autant d'attention à un filet
de maquereau
qu'à un filet de bar, etc.,
ou qu'à un homard.
Pour moi, c'est ça,
vraiment, l'idée de la bistronomie.
6Du très bon à un prix raisonnable,
c'est le défi que se sont lancé
Lucas, en cuisine,
et Chloé, en salle.
Les ingrédients sont
ultra frais, comme ce thon
de 5 kilos
que le chef cuisine ce matin.
-C'est un thon qui a été pêché
dans l'Atlantique.
Par ce qu'on appelle
des petits bateaux.
Donc qui a été pêché à la ligne,
pas par des gros chaluts.
Tu me demandais
ce que c'est la bistronomie,
c'est aussi savoir
utiliser les choses.
Et pas forcément jeter.
Cette partie-là, elle va être super
pour faire du cru, du tartare, etc.
Ca, il y a un chouïa
plus de nerf, on va le cuire.
-Au menu, thon snacké à la sauce
tomate piment fumé avec des figues,
des câpres et de la roquette,
une assiette de bistrot
travaillée comme dans un restaurant
gastronomique.
28 euros le menu,
4 fois moins qu'une table étoilée,
moins select plus conviviale,
une précision décontractée,
découverte chez vous,
Yves Camdeborde.
Lucas a fait ses classes
dans vos cuisines
et voilà ce qu'il en retient.
-Il m'a appris les pommes Dauphine
de son grand-père.
C'est pas forcément techniquement
ce qu'il m'a appris,
c'est une histoire de philosophie.
-Cette cuisine
de haute volée, plus abordable,
vous en êtes le pilier.
Retour dans les années 90,
la Régalade, votre restaurant,
va révéler un nouveau courant,
la bistronomie.
-On peut très bien exister, se faire
plaisir professionnellement,
donner du plaisir à ses clients,
sans s'identifier
à une institution privée
qui nous casse
les pieds.
-Le concept a un succès fou.
Le terme bistronomie entre même
dans le Larousse. Définition :
cuisine raffinée et inventive,
de type gastronomique,
mais servie dans un restaurant
simple, non étoilé.
-Tout le monde a cherché
à s'approprier cette bistronomie,
qui était une espèce de martingale,
de recette à succès.
Aujourd'hui, la bistronomie qualifie
une réalité extrêmement
diverse. Et après, vous mettez
désormais sous le terme
de bistronomie
un peu tout et n'importe quoi.
Elle est là, la réalité.
-Alors, Yves Camdeborde,
dans cette bistronomie
de 2023, y a-t-il
vraiment à boire et à manger ?
-Réponse, y a-t-il vraiment
à boire et à manger ?
-Oui, bien sûr. Tout le monde
veut s'approprier ce terme
qui a été dit la première fois
par Sébastien Demorand.
Voilà, j'avais jamais voulu faire...
C'est-à-dire
que Sébastien Demorand...
-Il vous gêne, ce terme ?
-Il m'a gêné à une époque.
-Pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas
Sébastien Demorand,
critique gastronomique, disparu.
-Un des journalistes gastronomiques
qui m'a le plus apporté
intellectuellement
de par ses critiques.
Il m'a dit un jour,
Yves, tu fais de la bistronomie.
C'est parti comme ça.
C'est devenu très marketing,
très médiatique,
qui des fois frise le ridicule, mais
le contre-exemple, c'est le Matré.
Lucas et Chloé se sont lancés
sans argent.
C'est eux qui ont peint,
ils ont pas appelé un architecte.
C'est eux qui ont mis la lumière,
ils ont pas appelé un designer.
Ils se sont débrouillés
avec leurs mains et leurs coeurs,
pour donner de la personnalité,
donner de l'amour
et faire une assiette
d'exception.
-Qu'est-ce qui vous gêne
dans la bistronomie ? On a le décor,
mais on s'y retrouve pas
dans l'assiette ?
-Moi, je sors du Ritz, du Crillon,
je quitte ça pour aller
dans un endroit, je veux
que le plus grand nombre
puisse bien manger dans un esprit
totalement décontracté.
Donc tout le décorum, je l'enlève.
Je pense qu'à une chose,
l'assiette. Aujourd'hui,
malheureusement,
une fois de plus,
on remet des codes
de partout, on remet
du décorum
avec le designer à la mode...
-Vous, c'était
pour nourrir
vos copains rugbymen.
-C'est pas mes copains,
pour nourrir les gens.
Le restaurant, on est en train
de faire des musées. Si on n'a pas
les codes, les bons comportements,
on ne peut plus y aller.
Un restaurant doit rester
un lieu de vie. Quand on rentre
dans un restaurant,
on doit pas être mal à l'aise...
-Mais l'ambiance,
ça joue beaucoup
pour se sentir bien dans un lieu.
-Oui, il faut aller au musée,
il faut aller au théâtre.
Un restaurant, avant tout,
c'est bien manger.
J'ai pas envie de payer 3 fois plus
cher parce qu'on va m'expliquer
que les rideaux, c'est Starck
ou Pierre Frey. Ca ne m'intéresse
pas. Qu'on me dise
que la volaille vient
de chez Pierre Duplantier,
une volaille d'exception
faite par un personnage
extraordinaire
qui respecte ses animaux
et qui nous amène
une matière première incroyable
et qu'on me la fasse déguster.
Je veux l'émotion du palais,
de toute ma sensibilité olfactive
et gustative.
C'est tout ce qui nous intéresse.
-Pour vous, les codes
de la bistronomie, c'est quoi ?
Du 100 % français dans l'assiette ?
-Pas obligatoirement.
-De la qualité supérieure ?
-C'est pas tellement
du 100 % français,
bien sûr, si on peut faire du
français, mais c'est pas interdit
de prendre un produit
de l'étranger exceptionnel
et le locavore aussi bien sûr,
mais moi qui suis béarnais,
j'ai le droit de faire
des endives, j'aime
les endives, je peux faire venir
des endives d'un artisan du Nord.
Pour moi,
c'est la limite du locavore.
Si je prends de l'agneau,
si je suis en Béarn,
il faut que je prenne
l'agneau des Pyrénées,
je le fais pas venir
du Mont-Saint-Michel.
La bistronomie,
la définition pour moi,
c'est une assiette d'exception
à un prix accessible
dans une très bonne ambiance.
-C'était la contraction de bistrot
et de gastronomie. Quels plats
incarnent... Il l'a dit,
François-Régis Gaudry,
c'est un peu tout et n'importe quoi.
Quels sont pour vous, si ça existe,
les plats qui incarnent
cette bistronomie ?
-Il y a pas de plats
qui l'incarnent.
On peut faire un turbot au caviar
dans la bistronomie,
mais au lieu de le vendre 250 euros,
on le vend 50.
-Vous vendez à perte.
C'est d'actualité cela dit.
-On vend pas à perte.
-Le caviar, ça a un prix.
-Je prends peut-être
un plat exagéré,
mais philosophiquement, c'est ça.
Faire un coefficient de 10 n'est pas
obligatoire.
-C'est pas un petit salé
aux lentilles.
-Non, c'est péjoratif.
-C'est une critique
contre les étoilés,
c'est qu'en fait,
ils font des marges
énormes sur le dos du client.
-Ils font des marges énormes,
ils sont obligés de le faire.
Le verre que j'achète en bistronomie
qui coûte 2,50, eux, ils prennent
un Zalto qui coûte 80 euros.
Voilà, il y a une logique.
-C'est pour compenser...
-Attention, je reviens dessus,
je ne dis pas
que la haute gastronomie
vole les clients. C'est faux.
Ils gagnent peut-être moins
que dans la bistronomie,
mais ils sont
dans l'excellence de tout,
donc le prix est dans l'excellence.
Il y a une logique à tout.
Le même vin qu'on va acheter
en bistronomie, on va faire
un coefficient de 3, eux,
de 4 ou 5 ou 6.
-L'exigence est-elle la même que
dans un restaurant gastronomique ?
-Oui.
C'est exactement la même.
La différence est là.
La bistronomie, Lucas le dit bien,
on a la même exigence.
C'est une obligation.
Mais attention, on a l'intelligence
de savoir
qu'on n'est pas 15 en cuisine,
on n'est que 2, donc on va aller
à un peu plus de simplicité
technique.
Quand on va prendre un maquereau,
on va prendre le même
qu'Eric Frechon achète au Bristol,
la même qualité, au même prix,
mais nous, on va simplement
le lever, le poêler,
l'agrémenter de garniture,
Eric va faire
un travail totalement différent
avec beaucoup plus d'interventions
de la main et de technique,
ça coûtera plus cher. Gustativement,
après, les goûts,
ce seront deux goûts
d'exception.
-C'est pas moins ambitieux
de vouloir faire de la bistronomie
quand on a été au Ritz,
dans des grandes
maisons comme vous ?
-Non, je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus humain.
Parce qu'on est proches
de nos clients, on aime nos clients,
on le voit avec Lucas,
il a la cuisine ouverte,
tout le monde va lui dire bonjour.
On a besoin humainement de vivre
le moment avec intensité.
Dans la haute gastronomie, c'est
le côté parfait, très rigide,
très organisé, très structuré,
où il y a pas le droit
de transpirer, il y a pas le droit
d'exister hors de l'assiette,
tandis que le bistronome
a envie d'exister.
-C'est pas une façon de renoncer
à l'étoilé, à cette charge mentale ?
Je fais bien mon métier,
mais je m'encombre pas
de cette charge.
-C'est là qu'ils se sont trompés,
ils ont loupé un coche.
Quoi qu'ils disent
dans tous leurs discours
qu'on a entendus depuis des années,
quand ils disent, c'est
que l'assiette, c'est pas vrai.
Et je crois que Michelin fait
une énorme erreur d'avoir totalement
délaissé cette bistronomie
pendant des années.
Je les défie de prendre
une assiette finie d'un bistrot,
qui est bien faite,
la mettre dans une grande maison
avec le décorum.
-Et là, il aura son étoile.
-Toute la problématique est là. Eric
Frechon.
Eric Frechon à la Verrière,
zéro étoile,
il passe au Bristol, 2 étoiles.
Et Eric, c'est un ami,
il a pas changé sa cuisine.
Eric, il a la même philosophie,
il avait la même précision
dans la Verrière à l'époque
qu'il a aujourd'hui au Bristol.
-Il y a une dictature
des étoiles aujourd'hui
dans la gastronomie ?
-Il faut pas oublier
que c'est un organisme privé.
Si on a envie de leur dire
un gros mot, on peut leur dire.
-Vous l'avez fait un peu.
-Oui, poliment.
-Poliment.
-Parce que j'ai été
déçu de leur part. J'ai été déçu,
j'ai travaillé dans un 3 étoiles
Michelin où c'était une catastrophe,
et c'était un 3 étoiles Michelin,
qu'on a cité tout à l'heure.
-Ceux qui auscultent
les tendances de la cuisine
française parlent du retour
de la cuisine bourgeoise.
Quelle différence
entre la cuisine bourgeoise
et cette bistronomie ?
La cuisine bourgeoise utilise
des bons produits. Elle est un peu
au coin du feu, moins innovante,
moins créative ? On ressort
des vieilles traditions ?
-C'est
la cuisine familiale, qui était
faite de plats très chaleureux.
-Ca peut être
une cuisine de bistronomie.
-Oui, mais ça peut être
aussi une cuisine de gastronomie.
Un boeuf bourguignon
fait par Jean-François Piège
dans son 2 étoiles Michelin,
ça sera merveilleux,
c'est sûr et certain.
-Comment voulez-vous
que les clients s'y retrouvent ?
Gastronomie, bistronomie, cuisine
bourgeoise, familiale...
-Il y a trop d'appellations.
On a eu une période très espagnole
avec la tendance espagnole
de Ferran Adrià,
on a eu une tendance
très asiatique
qui dure encore un petit peu,
on a eu une tendance très scandinave
avec ce qui s'est passé
en Scandinavie
dans la haute gastronomie
et aujourd'hui,
on se dit, en fin de compte,
le plus beau des voyages,
c'est faire le tour de soi-même
et quand on l'a fait,
on se dit, c'est pas si mal
que ça. Pourquoi on ferait pas
un saucisse-purée
fait à la perfection ?
-Avec des très bons produits.
Du goût.
-J'achète.
-En finalité, pourquoi l'émotion
du goût,
l'émotion que le palais pourrait
en dégager est pas aussi beau,
aussi jouissif
qu'un caviar d'exception ?
-La cuisine française a été
copiée.
La bistronomie est-elle copiée ?
On la retrouve à l'étranger ?
Ils nous envient ces petits bistrots
à la cuisine excellente ?
-Moi, j'ai toujours beaucoup...
Pas d'émotion du tout en plus,
mais toujours très surpris
de me balader dans le monde entier
et de voir le mot bistronomie
apparaître partout.
Dans n'importe quel pays, le mot,
même au Japon, ils le mettent pas en
japonais, c'est marqué bistronomie.
C'est un phénomène
du 14e arrondissement,
qui a gagné Paris,
la Province et le monde.
-Vous êtes exporté partout.
-Personne sait qui je suis.
Quand je passe...
-Briseur de grève,
faiseur de tendances !
-Ca a été fait
49 avenue Jean Moulin,
un restaurant peint
par mes copains de rugby.
Les tables, on les a achetées
au rabais aux puces.
-Aujourd'hui,
vous faites de la résistance.
-Ils peuvent pas s'imaginer ça.
On l'a fait avec nos valeurs,
et surtout on l'a fait sans savoir
ce qu'on faisait. Ma seule envie,
c'était respecter mon métier,
tous les maîtres
qui m'ont appris à travailler,
mais le faire dans la jouissance
et donner du bonheur à tous,
que le plaisir de bien manger
c'est pas réservé. En France,
le malheur aujourd'hui, c'est qu'il
y a encore des gens qui mangent mal
et ont pas de plaisir à manger.
C'est ça, le vrai drame.
C'était mon ambition, essayer de
faire plaisir au plus grand nombre.
-Il y en a d'autres
qui nous font plaisir, c'est
les joueurs de l'équipe
du monde de rugby,
il y a la Coupe du Monde.
On verra si elle est équipe
du monde, on ne sait pas encore...
-Pas trop vite, Brigitte.
-C'est bien parti. Vous êtes
un amateur du ballon
ovale, vous avez été
un grand joueur aussi
et vous êtes capitaine
du XV de la gastronomie.
Et vous êtes auteur de ce livre,
coauteur, "Ovalix", on l'a dit,
qui mêle donc les recettes
et un peu la 3e mi-temps. Mais
pour assurer sur le terrain, il faut
manger équilibré.
On met les pieds dans le plat.
-Yves, c'est sans doute lié
à leur gabarit hors-norme,
les rugbymen aiment bien manger,
on connaît leur passion pour les 3e
mi-temps pantagruéliques, mais avant
les matchs, la diététique
reprend ses droits.
Pierre-Mickaël Carniel
et Vincent Ferreira se sont rendus
à Port-de-Bouc à l'occasion du
Mondial amateur de rugby. Reportage.
-Aujourd'hui,
on fait tomber de suite.
Les règles à la française,
il faut les jouer. On les prend,
on les fait tomber. Ils font pas
1 m. Aux jambes, aux jambes.
Aux jambes. Toute la partie.
-Avant de dévorer ses adversaires,
le match se joue dans les assiettes.
Les joueurs du Rugby Club
de Digne-les-Bains
représentent la France,
ils mangent 3h avant le 1er match
un repas sur-mesure.
Ces colosses ont besoin
d'un apport calorique de 4000 kcal
par jour contre 2500 en moyenne
pour un homme adulte.
-C'est un repas sportif.
Qui est composé de poulet,
de pâtes, de lentilles,
une madeleine,
un yaourt et les couverts.
Evidemment, de l'eau.
La bière, c'est après.
Rires
-Des glucides, des lipides
et beaucoup de protéines,
le rugby amateur s'inspire
des codes nutritionnels
des sportifs de haut niveau.
-Sans faire de pub, si vous mangez
un fast-food avant le match,
ça va pas être la même chose
que des féculents.
Les professionnels,
ils ont des diététiciennes,
des personnes qui gèrent
leur alimentation. Nous, on essaie
de faire attention quand même,
mais ça reste amateur,
donc on peut pas contraindre
les garçons à manger équilibré
tous les jours
avec des menus adaptés.
Ils font le haka.
-Ce jour-là, les Français affrontent
une équipe néo-zélandaise,
elle aussi semble avoir faim.
Et quand les rencontres
s'enchaînent,
les joueurs peuvent perdre
jusqu'à 2 l d'eau par heure,
alors même la composition de l'eau
n'est pas laissée au hasard.
-On la récupère, les gars ! Allez !
Pour la mi-temps essentiellement,
on rajoute un peu de compléments
pour la récupération. Dedans,
il y a du sucre, des sels minéraux.
C'est très important,
surtout pour la suite, parce qu'on a
une accumulation de matchs.
On a un 2e match derrière.
Donc il faut que tous les organismes
soient toujours prêts.
-Les All Blacks amateurs
l'emportent contre les Bleus,
mais peu importe le score,
place à la célèbre 3e mi-temps.
Toutes les équipes partagent
ce qu'elles appellent un gueuleton,
un repas copieux et festif.
-Du coup, on mange
tous ensemble religieusement
une soupe de poisson
bien marseillaise.
Ca tranche un peu
avec le repas de ce midi.
Ce midi, c'était très axé
protéines, sucres lents.
Ce soir, c'est plus
l'ambiance à la bonne humeur.
On a passé une bonne journée.
-C'est l'apéritif.
-Voilà.
-Là, surtout, c'est un moment
de convivialité, de partage.
Le rugby amateur, c'est surtout ça,
c'est le rugby, c'est l'ovalie,
c'est les copains.
Là, on est tous ensemble, on partage
un beau moment de convivialité.
-Et on se permet même
quelques excès.
-Moi, je préfère le rouge.
Dans un verre Clan Campbell.
-Là !
-J'ai lu ça et vous avez dû
connaître cette époque,
dans les années 80,
l'équipe de France avant un match
dévorait
un pantagruélique cassoulet.
C'est plus possible aujourd'hui ?
-Avant un match. Il faut pas oublier
que, dans les années 80,
le rugby était un sport amateur.
-C'était l'équipe de France.
-Oui, mais c'était aussi
des amateurs. Donc ils avaient
le comportement d'un jeu amateur.
-Aujourd'hui, il faut
manger équilibré
pour être un grand sportif.
Sans excès.
-De toute façon,
on voit déjà par rapport aux corps
des joueurs de rugby
qui sont devenus des athlètes.
Je dis toujours, ils ressemblent
tous à des décathloniens.
Ils sont magnifiques. L'alimentation
est très importante, primordiale,
et ils y font très attention.
Ce qui empêche pas, par exemple,
après la Coupe du Monde,
il y aura un joli banquet.
-Il y a toujours
des 3e mi-temps ?
-Oui,
elles font partie de la culture,
c'est un moment de fraternité.
C'est un peu ce que j'ai vécu
avec Monsieur Gayssot,
Monsieur Palmié et Monsieur Paris.
C'est que la table fait
qu'il y a un partage, de l'amour,
qui s'instaure et qui amène
beaucoup de lien
et cette fameuse fraternité
qui fait partie vraiment
de l'ADN du rugby.
Vous, vous faisiez vivre cette table
avec vos copains du rugby
quand vous étiez joueur ?
-Oui. On perpétuait ces traditions.
-C'était vous qui cuisiniez
pour les copains ?
-Oui,
c'était un petit club amateur
de 3e division,
il y avait toujours un barbecue,
quelqu'un aux grillades
et souvent, en tant que cuisinier,
je me retrouvais aux grillades.
-Eve Tiollier est
la nutritionniste du XV de France.
Vous avez des contacts avec elle ?
Vous aimez bien la bouffe plaisir.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils mangent
le XV de France avant le match
contre l'Italie ?
-Non, je l'aide pas du tout,
c'est une professionnelle
et j'ai pas les compétences
de diététicien
pour accompagner le XV de France,
je suis plutôt intervenant
sur l'après-match.
Ils vont manger équilibré.
-Est-ce que tout est pesé,
le moindre gramme de protéine ?
-Peut-être pas,
mais l'équilibre nutritionnel, c'est
sûr qu'il est là et surtout,
l'équilibre nutritionnel est fait
en fonction de chaque individu.
-Certains pèsent 120 kilos.
-Voilà, quand on nourrit
un joueur comme Atonio
qui fait 150 kilos
et qu'on nourrit à côté de ça
un Thomas Ramos,
c'est pas du tout la même...
Il y a pas besoin
de la même quantité
ni même sans doute
du même équilibre nutritionnel.
Chacun a un équilibre
nutritionnel spécifique.
-Il y a ce livre, "Ovalix",
que vous avez coécrit. C'est quoi,
l'histoire de ces recettes
avec finalement le XV ?
-Alors,
"Ovalix", je l'ai coécrit
avec Olivier Margot, qui est
l'ancien rédacteur en chef
pendant 25 ans du journal L'Equipe
et amoureux de rugby,
ancien joueur de rugby.
L'idée part de se dire,
le banquet est très important,
il faut le mettre en valeur.
On est allés rechercher des vieux
banquets, des vieux menus
de banquets, pour des matchs
historiques dans l'histoire
de la... du rugby français.
-Il y a les menus,
les photos.
-Du siècle dernier même.
-Olivier raconte
l'histoire du match,
j'en raconte aussi certaines
que j'ai vécues.
Il raconte l'histoire du banquet
et systématiquement
par rapport à chaque menu,
je retire
une matière première du menu
et je m'amuse à faire une recette,
une recette qui est
facile à faire, en me disant,
si j'ai des copains qui viennent
voir le match de rugby,
qu'est-ce que je peux leur faire ?
-Alors, c'est plutôt à picorer
ou c'est... Devant la télé,
pour regarder le match.
-C'est à picorer devant la télé,
mais des recettes engagées comme
au rugby, qui ont du caractère,
où il y a pas d'indifférence,
qui vont être surprenantes,
mais des recettes plaisir
et accessibles à tous.
-Pas qu'à picorer, Brigitte,
parce que le magret de canard
en carpaccio...
-Ca, c'est
à picorer.
-Il faut des fourchettes.
-Oui, avec une fourchette
ou avec des pics.
-Pas du snacking.
-J'ai vu la tarte aux Saint-Jacques.
-Les oeufs pochés au saumon gelé,
ça, ça se partage.
-Ca donne des idées aussi peut-être
aux personnes qui nous regardent.
-L'Irish Coffee et ses tuiles
salées, ça se partage moins.
-Il peut y avoir 3 pailles.
En plus, chaque plat a aussi
une petite histoire
par rapport au match.
La tarte au chocolat,
la tarte au chocolat a été créée
par Christian Constant
à l'hôtel Crillon
pour les joueurs
de l'équipe de France
de la fin des années 80, dont
Pascal Ondarts et Grégoire Lascubé,
gourmands et fanatiques du chocolat.
Capitale du chocolat
en France, Bayonne,
on a voulu rendre hommage
à tous ces joueurs du Pays basque
en leur créant
cette tarte au chocolat.
-Je l'ai vue, la tarte.
-Vous êtes aussi capitaine du XV
de la gastronomie. Racontez-nous
cette histoire. Vous intervenez
aussi sur cette Coupe du Monde
de Rugby.
-Oui,
j'interviens
sur la Coupe du Monde.
C'est une idée
de Claude Atcher, qui m'a contacté
pour me dire, ce serait bien
que, pour une fois,
une coupe du monde de rugby,
surtout en France,
on mette en valeur la haute
gastronomie. Le rugby est reconnu,
mais la plus belle gastronomie
au monde est la Française.
Claude m'a demandé d'accompagner
tous les traiteurs de France
qui interviennent
dans les stades, dans les 9 stades,
et on est 23 cuisiniers,
comme une équipe de cuisine.
-C'est un XV à 23.
Il y a aussi le banc de touche avec.
-En rugby, on est 23,
15 qui jouent et avec
les 8 remplaçants.
-On s'arrange.
-On a accompagné les traiteurs,
on a choisi les menus, on a imposé
un cahier des charges,
recettes régionales,
recettes de saison
et un maximum de produits locavores.
Là, ça a été fait en amont.
Depuis 2 ans, on a beaucoup
travaillé main dans la main
avec les traiteurs.
Aujourd'hui, on est 3 par stade,
par match, il y a systématiquement
3 membres du XV de la gastronomie.
-Donc 3 chefs.
-Oui.
-Donc on mange pas
la même chose.
-On voulait pas une uniformité
globale de l'ensemble du territoire,
on voulait que chaque région,
chaque stade transpire
et sente la gastronomie.
-Ce sont des traiteurs
locaux, ce sont pas
les grands chefs qui cuisinent.
-On les accompagne. Alain Ducasse,
Jean-François Piège,
Alexandre Gauthier,
Christian Etchebest, Stéphanie
Le Quellec, Amandine Chaignot,
Christelle Brua, que des amoureux
de ce sport et des amoureux
de la gastronomie.
On s'est mis au service,
totalement bénévolement,
de ce magnifique
événement qui se passe en France.
On est très fiers.
Quand on rentre
dans les stades,
on voit cette bouille réjouie
de l'ensemble des spectateurs
en train de consommer,
ça peut être un simple sandwich
ou dans une loge ou dans un salon.
C'est pour tout le monde.
-Toutes les bourses.
-Oui, on est intervenus
sur tous les produits
servis dans les stades.
-On va bien manger au stade.
C'est une bonne nouvelle.
Puisqu'on a fini, on va passer
au dessert, c'est le péché mignon.
-Passons au sucré,
Yves est passé
à la crème caramel.
-J'ai goûté.
-Mais vous avez raison.
Un dessert, figurez-vous, connu
dès le Moyen Age en France.
Plus tard appelé
flaon, dessert qui ne va cesser de
se populariser au fil des siècles,
jusqu'à cette version moderne
avec du caramel,
préparée et cuite au bain-marie,
mentionné pour la 1re fois
dans "La cuisine provençale",
publié en 1997.
Est-ce bien votre dessert préféré
ou un message subliminal envoyé
aux rugbymen,
soyez des crèmes dans la vie
et sur le terrain, mettez
des caramels aux adversaires ?
-Non, c'est mon dessert préféré.
J'adore les crèmes prises.
Elle est très, très bonne.
Elle est très équilibrée,
très peu collée
avec des oeufs, elle garde
ce côté très soyeux,
une très belle réussite.
-Digne de la bistronomie ?
-Oui, mais de la gastronomie aussi.
-Ah pardon.
-Je vais me fâcher.
-De la cuisine bourgeoise aussi.
-Une superbe crème caramel,
c'est un dessert merveilleux.
-Vous la faites comment,
votre crème caramel ?
-Je fais
pas mieux que ça pour être franc.
Je m'amuse à mettre
des feuilles de laurier
dans le lait, quand je fais
bouillir mon lait,
j'infuse des feuilles
de laurier dedans.
Je trouve que ça amène un twist
très agréable, totalement différent.
Le laurier en pâtisserie,
on l'utilise très, très peu.
C'est plus souvent avec le poisson.
J'adore ce côté du laurier qui amène
beaucoup de fraîcheur
et peut-être une âme supplémentaire.
-Votre astuce,
je vais essayer.
-Juste infusée.
-Vous testez pour moi.
-Très agréable.
-Peut-on être
aussi bon en salé qu'en sucré ?
Vous êtes aussi à l'aise
quand vous faites de la pâtisserie
qu'un plat...
-Je suis aussi à l'aise
en sucré qu'en salé,
mais ma spécialité
reste quand même le salé.
Et on dit, voilà, nous,
on fait des desserts de cuisinier.
Là, la crème caramel, c'est vraiment
typiquement un dessert de cuisinier.
Je vais pas concurrencer
un Christophe Michalak
ou un Felder ou un Pierre Hermé,
qui sont des purs pâtissiers
et qui font des desserts techniques.
Pratiquement aujourd'hui,
c'est tous des oeuvres d'art.
Nous, les cuisiniers...
-C'est quoi les desserts
de cuisinier ?
-La crème caramel.
-La mousse
au chocolat ?
-Une mousse au chocolat.
Une crêpe Suzette,
un soufflé chaud au Grand Marnier,
une omelette norvégienne, une tarte
fine aux pommes, on est plus
sur des classiques de cuisinier.
C'est pas la pâtisserie
qui est une pâtisserie
très artistique
avec beaucoup de technique.
-Il y a le duel
crème caramel-crème brûlée.
Vous êtes plutôt
crème brûlée ou caramel ?
-Je mettrais pas de duel,
les deux sont très bonnes
quand elles sont bien réalisées.
-Il faut choisir.
-Pourquoi toujours choisir ?
-Votre choix,
vous avez choisi crème caramel.
-Vous faites des menus, vos clients
doivent choisir.
Vous proposez le choix.
-C'est moi qui choisis. Par exemple,
je vais faire crème caramel l'hiver
et je vais faire
crème brûlée l'été.
La crème caramel,
je trouve que c'est
plus rond, plus chaleureux,
et le côté crème brûlée, c'est
un chaud-froid qui est différent.
C'est deux choses différentes,
mais bien faites,
elles sont exceptionnelles.
Arrêtons
de choisir, je veux manger les deux.
-Alors, puisque vous voulez tout,
on va écouter à présent
une musique que vous avez choisie.
Et vous allez nous dire
pourquoi juste après.
"Mon vieux", Daniel Guichard
...
Dans son vieux pardessus râpé
Il s'en allait l'hiver, l'été
Dans le petit matin frileux
...
Mon vieux
-Alors, cette chanson,
vous avez l'air ému, non ?
Pourquoi vous l'avez choisie ?
C'est Daniel Guichard.
-Oui,
parce que j'ai mon papa qui a 92 ans
et qui est pas bien du tout,
voilà qui est en train
tout doucement
de partir dans l'au-delà,
donc voilà.
-C'était un petit hommage.
-Oui. Parce que c'est
quelqu'un d'important,
comme tous les papas
pour tout le monde, quand c'est
son papa et qui m'a accompagné toute
ma vie, c'est toujours particulier.
Vous allez me faire pleurer.
-Votre papa vous a donné envie
de faire ce métier ?
-Oui.
-Il avait une ferme ?
-Oui, il avait une ferme
et il m'a donné surtout
envie de vivre.
-Mais de faire ce que vous aimiez ?
-Oui, voilà, de vivre
heureux, de pas avoir de complexes,
même si c'est pas bien
ce qu'on fait,
si ça te fait plaisir, fais-le.
C'était l'exemple
quand on se faisait attraper
quand on était jeunes,
quand on avait fait des bêtises,
il nous grondait, mais il nous
disait, soyez intelligents,
vous faites pas attraper.
-Il doit être fier.
-Oui, bien sûr.
Je suis surtout très fier
d'être son fils.
-Ce papa qui vous a appris
à faire la brandade.
-Oui, qui m'a appris.
Comme tous les papas, je pense,
il m'a donné une philosophie et
une façon de me comporter, de vivre.
-On lui dédie
cette émission alors.
-Je vous remercie.
-Merci
infiniment
d'avoir partagé la table
avec nous.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Merci à Chez Françoise qui
nous a servi ces très bons plats.
-Très, très bons.
-Merci à vous de nous avoir suivis.
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...